deaths from opiate overdoses are falling
drastically in states that have
legalized marijuana we've been following
Jeff Sessions and the Justice
Department's promise to crack down on
marijuana and on states that have
already decided to legalize it because
of course states rights don't matter to
Republicans if they don't want you
legalizing weed meanwhile we're actually
seeing marijuana legislation
legalization legislation having a
positive impact on drug overdoses and
it's also having a positive financial
impact for states that have legalized
according to a new study by UC San Diego
which was published in a journal called
drug and alcohol dependence states that
have legalized marijuana have had a
fewer well number one they're not having
marijuana related emergency room visits
so those scare tactics about people are
going to OD you're going to have
emergency rooms filled with people on
marijuana Rhett that hasn't happening
that hasn't been happening but we're
also seeing fewer people on opiates come
into emergency rooms and on average in
states that have legalized weed
hospitals have seen a twenty three
percent decline in patients seeking
opiate addiction treatment and there's
been a thirteen percent decline in
opioid overdoses this is the fifth
recent study to show drops in opiate
addiction in states that have legalized
marijuana it's not one study that says
this in response to the study dr. esther
chu who's an emergency medicine
professor at oregon health and science
university said quote it is becoming
increasingly clear that battling the
opioid epidemic will require a
multi-pronged approach and a good deal
of creativity could increase
liberalisation of marijuana be part of
the solution it seems plausible there's
a 2014 study which found a twenty five
percent drop in opioid overdose deaths
in states with legal medical marijuana
and we're now seeing the same impact
with legal recreational marijuana as a
reminder an alternative view on
marijuana legalization jeff Sessions
said last month in Richmond Virginia the
Attorney General of the United States I
am astonished to hear people suggest
that we can solve our heroin crisis by
legalizing marijuana so people can trade
one life wrecking dependency on another
jeff Sessions has also said that
marijuana is only slightly less awful
than heroin on a saner note Democratic
Senator Claire McCaskill of Missouri is
leading an investigation of the
manufacturers of the top five
prescription opioid medications in the
US and they want to explore how these
companies have contributed to opioid
over utilization and over prescription
there's nothing surprising in the data
no nothing surprising at all what I
continue to be shocked by is people who
think that marijuana and heroin are in
any way the same thing in terms of the
damage they caused or the way that they
function in the body or anything at all
period and number two the idea that
anything approximating the war on drugs
is going to be good in any sense
incarceration health outcomes anything
how does anybody still believe that at
this point I don't get it and what's the
top argument against legalizing
marijuana that marijuana is a gateway
drug and it will cause people to move on
to opiates and heroin once they get sick
or tired of using marijuana these
studies kind of show the opposite
absolutely absolutely they do and you
know I don't know how much people know
about this but it's very common that
people who ultimately get addicted to
heroin it starts with a legitimate
prescription for opiate painkillers
often over prescribed and addictive by
nature even if properly prescribed
people say well I need more of these my
prescriptions out I'm going to go by
painkillers on the street then they
realize oh the heroin is cheaper than
the painkillers it's a disaster it is an
absolute and total disaster and I'm glad
that this research is being done